c'est vrai quand tu étais petit que les
prix grec à l'école parce que ont été
dispensés de cours de chant une chose
est vraie c'est vrai parce que j'étais
tellement timide tu as dit j'ai pas la
foi mais j'ai du mal à croire qu'ils
aient pas un metteur en scène suprême
quoi se dire est-ce retrouvant de tout
ce que les gens savent encore moi c'est
comment te dire est aux escales à aa
il est dès lors il faut rien ses toiles
réalisées tous faits odieux ya les
teintes et à dire en usine
oui j'ai passé trois ans nous n c'était
os en valeur sa voix tu sais toute leur
palette et qui au départ le pastel comme
ça qu'on a fait sur la grande muraille
de chine qu'esquisser sur moi et en
musique qui compte avait les cheveux
bleus préconisé la formule 1 c'est une
grande histoire et cordiaux vous aussi
parce qu'on t'a appelé pour terminer un
film s'appelait vendetta ou est ce que
tu sais ça
alors un jour tu vois la pub c'est ce
qu'a fait c'est vrai dans ce cas c'est
bien je sais tout
toutefois christophe hiou délégué leurs
parts kemper tourquennois nomades et
entre 18 et 22 ans tu te buter balader
ou et avec des manuscrits souvent les
maisons d'édition c'est vrai que
l'opérateur compte a fait la scène a dit
est ce vraiment nécessaire c'est vrai
c'est qu'elle recherche merde ici c'est
bien ce que c'est
you start et de plaines violin à des age
of china a dû nova c'est quand j'ai pris
en tournant en éclats de verre dont neuf
incidents ennemi intime 120 jeudi on est
resté cinq jours à l'hosto ouais ouais
j'ai mis c'est tout et toi tu as regardé
la télé et à regarder le foot à la télé
toi voilà comment tu sais ça et je sais
que tu as dit que c'était un apprenti
léo ferré ouais ouais t'es bien
renseigné tout dit les échos you got it
from de tête machine alors la saison tu
as fait un concours organisé par le
comité international de la laine et tu
as fait un petit manteau en chèvre john
incroyablement rapide et non oui la
préhistoire j'ai pris mon ma mère c'est
vrai mais écoutez
tes parents j'avais amené à la manif du
général de gaulle le 20 et le 30 mai 68
et une tech chasse la taille
[Musique]
il faut lier la maison carrée à côté de
chez lui pour le sauver je sais tout cas
tous liés aux pitots au niveau de doctor
who art in a commencé très jeunes
commencent à 15 ans oui mais peuvent-ils
c'est tout et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de inhabituel abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux